je suis très heureux de rencontrer miss
france 2000 22 dernières haies les
manifs retrait vraiment j'avais voté
pour vous
ce que je suis de l'île de france bien
entendu alors vous êtes dans
l'immobilier tout à fait en promotion
promotion tout c'est à dire c'est quoi
comme je suis mobilières d'accord c'est
quand vous faites vous vendez des
apparts c'est un petit peu le stéphane
plaza mange
on boit beaucoup cité en ce moment non
mais c'est ça qu'on va se rencontrer on
pourra dire qu'on est cologne mais
agréable je pense qu'il a envie de vous
rencontrer des vins locaux des centres
qui peut le bruit d'un toit doré doit
rencontrer non mais et donc c'est vrai
donc hélas vous vendiez des maisons
voire des comptes sans rigoler diane qui
vous fait visiter n'importe quoi moi je
prends la même si j'ai pas le crédit
règne du tout dans c'est bon c'est bon
signe direct c'est bon non mais vous
savez je ne sais pas agent immobilier à
d'accord c'est un peu plus bas on nous
montre des terrains ont proposé
projetteront fait la promotion de ce
qu'on fait du terrain donc que son bloc
à la découpe alors ça y est vous avez
maintenant une nouvelle
chasse et sa compagne j'ai envie de dire
c'est un duo maintenant vous êtes
heureuse alors vous diana ce que vous la
voulez vous qu nettoyer un peu toutes
les miss qu'il s'était fait partie de
vos favorites pas chez gm faisait partie
des favoris depuis j'ai fait plusieurs
semaines au grand public et de la presse
et je trouve que mercy delphine parce
que c'est très bien cette année dassier
n'est dans le jury elle est belle on a
très bien résumé ce qui se passe en fait
entre ce que l'on voit à la télévision
et que vous vous ressentez en tentant de
lui parce qu'il ya plein de gens qui ont
dit oui c'est vrai qu'il ya le public
qui vote c'est 50-50 et où je trouve ça
ça amène un truc quand même voilà qui
est possible vote du jury parce que
voilà cc je trouve ça il faut ça vous
n'avez pas le changer on aura toujours
le jury je trouve que c'est ça marche
bien comme ça il ya des années
effectivement ou c
le vote du public est le même que le
vote du jury parfois ça change un peu
moi je trouve ça bien
cette année les questions des cinq
étaient très très difficile je pense que
c'est ça la différence est fait là le
jury a été un peu plus exigeant en fait
sur les réponses des cinq peut-être que
le public exactement c'est vrai alors on
voulait revoir votre discours diane vous
avez été excellentes crois que c'est ça
aussi quelques mois sur le disco vous
avez bossé avant ou pas jouer à fond
quand on fait des répétitions et ou
alors vous allez à 100% et est bien sûr
toujours ici
le discours je l'échangé la veille ah
ouais ben en fait c'est ce que j'ai dans
discours quand j'ai vu qu'ils avaient
dîné serait égal mettre ça dans le jury
je me suis dit je vais pas faire de
blagues en fait bref c'est absolument
impossible parce qu'elle voulait faire
des blagues au départ non c'est tout
pour moi
mais je m'étais dit il faut mettre un
peu d'humour montrer sa personnalité et
rage mais si la blague et les ratés il
ya deux humoristes en face ses katas ses
katas ouais mais il faut pas tenter la
blague et au final c'est ce qui a fait
rire les gens donc de dire ça alors
finalement on va regarder valait mieux
changer il y avait notre jean pierre
d'amours les deux jean pierre qu'on aime
d'ailleurs jean pierre pernaut président
et jean pierre foucault voilà qui ont
été excellentes tous les deux voilà
comment ce fort
apprécié personnes positives spontanée
souriante au multi nature peinture alors
vous le savez ma région et multiculturel
et c'est la raison pour laquelle ce soir
si j'ai la chance d'être élue miss
france j'aimerais soutenir le vivre
ensemble
j'aimerais rajouter que la plupart des
français passent par ma région un moment
dans leur vie que ce soit pour le
travail ou pour les études alors
finalement on a un peu comme une terre
d'adoption n'ont donc ce soir ça à mon
tour de vous demander pour un an
seulement adopté mois
vous avez peur de bafouiller ou un truc
comme ça en fait mon chapelet 15e là
donc c'est la place la future away c'est
à dire que pour deux raisons
premièrement parce que quand ils disent
au micro il reste une place et qu'il ya
14 ans filles à côté de moi je regarde à
ma gauche j y allais pas mal quand même
ici mouzin
midi pyrénées a le mérite aussi et là ça
va être compliqué la dernière classe et
donc quand j'entends mon nom il ya un
soulagement énorme et c'est pour ça que
je pense que le discours historique pour
la stella spontanément et ça parce que
je suis tellement soulagé tellement
heureuse que il sort comme ça et en même
temps il ya un pincement au coeur mais
c'est les 14 autres copines derrière
parce que vous êtes devenue copine ah
bah oui oui ça va ensemble quand même
j'avais des numéros pour orgue et aux
jantes ont
[Rires]
donc vrai forcément il ya des années
qu'il ya des biens qui seraient
évidemment moi ma meilleure amie d'
aventure c'était midi pyrénées et au
moment chapelet je me retranche derrière
dgdi bas d'une manière fance est
comprise mais je lui ai dit dans
l'élevage ensuite c'est je pars avec les
chartes de miss ile de france midi
pyrénées en dessous quoi c'est sa part
pour nous voilà c'est bon et très mignon
sylvie à quel moment vous vous êtes tous
habitent ou enfin vous savez tout vous
sentez les choses et est la spécialiste
actuellement vous êtes dit je pensais
que ça allait être miss ile de france
qui ait ce qui à un moment il ya eu un
déclic au moment du discours mon truc
vous êtes dit ça y est c'est s'il doit
répondre à cette question parce que là
il ya la présentation des 15 mai après
long ces fameuses cinq questions cette
année on avait fait une demande de
questions auprès du public puis que vous
envoyez des questions de 2000 question a
sélectionné cinq étaient vraiment
difficiles et on sait que jusqu'au bout
tout peut basculer ce soir donc quand
j'ai commencé à entendre les réponses
sur les questions des cinq on va dire
que mon choix s'est affinée et je me
doutais que l'ile-de-france aller très
loin vous dire allez allez allez voir
alors du coup de votre discours a été
très bon mais c'est vrai que c'est
toujours les miss il y en a qui sont un
peu plus tendue d'autres
non non non les
élites et fraternité est la devise de la
france pensez vous que cette devise soit
encore d'actualité
eh bien je pense en effet que cette
devise est toujours d'actualité
mon choix c'est de me me mon choix c'est
m e et surtout pour la jeunesse
apparemment la graisse française et qui
osent s'aventurer dans des choses leur
pardon qui osent s'aventurer dans des
aventures à mes yeux les ministres sont
représente plus qu'un simple concours de
beauté j'aime autant la gastronomie
française ça tombe bien puisque
ça tombe bien puisque
je n'ai pas la prétention de pouvoir
tout changer mais devenir votre passif
de ce soir serait un grand honneur
chouly
[Applaudissements]
ça doit être une très grosse angoisse
franchement ça doit être un enfer et je
comprends moi je moi je moi j'aurais
chiron truc c'est que du petit savonnage
ouais c'est ça oui mais moi moi j'aurais
fait une cata mois a franchement
j'aurais dit moi je suis arrivée là
j'aurais dit non mais j'aurais dit à
jean pierre laisse tomber dans la dame
après ça peut dire parce que quand même
sur scène ces défis qui ont entre 18 et
24 ans elles ont jamais très dur en quoi
c'est très dur je sais comment
j'entendais bbc pour ça on applaudissait
tous on est on vraiment à fond des
relais copine parce que je croyais que
j'étais content que ce dialogue va se
planter
alors c'est terrible non mais vraiment
on apris en disant ça va ça va sortir
tout seul c'est pas grave ça s'arrêtait
là alors moi j'ai failli chuter un temps
c'est vrai que j'ai fait j'ai poussé par
de l'azoté glisse au tennis au talent